turn it back on to the same song again
to get it together told you I'm screwed
up man I got to get back in the groove
specifically the New York groove
give me my zoom though give me the zoom
get it
the man that seems a song it's a
degenerate I will not sit here and allow
you to malign Ace Frehley give me the
soup it's not helping we haven't even
looked over yet
me
seize the moment you tried to kill her
he said I'd be saving the universe kill
either of you if it would stop that
blinking light the coded message channel
was just been on mantas a blinking
yellow light indicates an important
secret coded message shame on how long
this was your job
it was his job Jax you didn't see the
blinking yellow light did but you said
if it was yellow let it Mellow brown
flush it down those were your orders
isn't talking about the coded message 22
important coded secret messages that
could have been helpful five hours I've
been sitting five hours
we have 22 messages 23 messages oh I
keep coming in from nebula Kimura is
alive danos is taking her to Titan why
aren't you responding why aren't you
responding
are you getting my important coded
secret messages ship coordinates how do
we know this isn't a trap
[Music]
you